[Music]
like to get set on fire three two one
[Music]
welcome to a sunny but deceivingly icy
hungry well we're here on the set of the
last Kingdom to meet legendary stuntman
Levent a who's going to be showing me
the ropes and some of their stunts booze
that they use on the show hey Luis how
are you so first of all that come to the
set of the last Kingdom Dreamlands for
every stunt performer getting the titles
out night it's gonna be like WWE in it
it's a bit unnerving when you boys are
all talking to each other because I'm
not I'm like a scientist let's smash him
through that table of so he will lift
you up and they all come together and
then you do a small fight like this
[Music]
small fight you just text free gazes
then over block boom boom
[Music]
so I'm hurting quite a lot right now and
I've just been told I'm about to be set
on fire
[Music]
no no no how's it feel that's white I'm
a nut we always use water jail it's got
this consistency of semen we're going to
get set on fire
so ready ready
okay standing ready okay three two one
[Music]
a little bit scared then you screamed me
acting wrong
it's been a blinder
having no idea of what to expect them
today the last thing I thought it would
be happening with flames on my back so
yeah it's been exhilarating and the
extras in your team doesn't give me your
contact than though you remember
consuming a sword like me thank you
the the adrenaline is now subsided and
it's you know it's kind of coming to
terms with the fact I've just been set
on fire I think the fire was enough for
me to be like I'm hanging up my stuntman
boots I'm hoping I can get a shower
because I can't see them letting me on
an aeroplane stinking of gasoline like I
do right now so that's probably next off
[Music]
you
[Music]